bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on parlait des gilet
jaune avec jérôme rodrigues il a appelé
à ne pas manifester ce samedi en raison
de l'épidémie du coronavirus un appel
qui n'a pas été entendu puisque ils sont
actuellement plusieurs centaines de
manifestants à déambuler actuellement
dans les rues de paris votre sentiment
sur le sujet écoutez si c'est une
centaine de personnes je pense que c'est
raisonnable sans 200 personnes à
l'extérieur je pense que c'est
raisonnable maintenant sur le fond est
ce que il est bien oui bon écoutez ce
que sur le fond est ce qu'il était
indispensable de devoir se produire dans
les rues de paris à un moment où on
attend quand même un petit peu de de
faire partie d'une comité de la
communauté nationale je suppose sûr je
ne suis pas sûr je suis pas allergique
au gilet jaune comme vous le savez j'ai
pas une prévention particulière à leur
encontre
mais enfin un gilet jaune est un
français il me semble et en ce moment je
souhaiterais que l'on réagisse un peu à
l'italienne
vous voyez alors justement on y arrive
cette semaine le gouvernement a annoncé
sa stratégie pour combattre la crise
interdiction des rassemblements de plus
de 100 personnes fermeture des crèches
et des établissements scolaires vous
pensez que ces mesures vont suffire pour
enrayer l'épidémie
écoutez
vous ne questionner pas un spécialiste
des infections
donc j'ai tendance à devoir m'en
remettre à la communauté à l'opinion
majoritaire de la communauté
scientifique qui elles-mêmes divisées
notamment sur cette histoire décolle
donc je n'ai pas une confiance aveugle
dans les décisions mais une fois que les
décisions sont prises
je crois que le meilleur moyen c'est
s'en remettre mais puisque vous
m'interrogez là dessus je crois que nous
ne devons pas réagir et nous n'aurions
pas dû réagir en idéologue
donc lorsqu'on a beaucoup ri lorsque des
gens comme marine le pen eric ce que ti
ou celui qui vous parle
penser qu'il n'était pas indispensable
de ce que des avions au tout début de
l'épidémie 1
au tout début de de chine atterrissent à
paris où des avions qui venait de teyran
où même des avions qui venait de
d'italie ou même des italiens qui
prenait le qui venait par la route
lorsqu'on a parlé de frontières
justement on a expliqué que c'était nous
les idéologues or qui sont véritablement
et les idéologues
j'observe que des gens qui sont
peut-être pas beaucoup plus bêtes que
nous dans le monde ont fermé les
frontières
regardez comment taïwan a su à quelques
à quelques kilomètres de la chine se
protéger en fermant justement ses
frontières les israël qui connaît assez
bien les notions de prophylaxie et
maintenant à maintenant interdit à
certains membres de la communauté
européenne
issus de pays considérés comme plus à
risque d'atterrir à tel aviv
je ne suis pas sûr que les israéliens
soient beaucoup plus bêtes que nous donc
vous pensez qu'il faut mettre en place
des mesures un peu plus drastiques des
mises en quarantaine des fermetures de
frontières un confinement à généraliser
pourquoi est ce que justement le
gouvernement peine à arriver jeu
que là que ce serait à ce que ce serait
un jour mnc rêver alors je vous savez je
ne sais pas si les 11h55 ou 12h05
je ne sais pas s'il est trop tard
maintenant pour cela j'observe
simplement que notre président de la
république a considéré que c'était les
frontières de schengen qui devait
peut-être être protégé alors même qu'on
sait que le sait l'europe qui au centre
même actuellement du virus
donc là encore c'est agir en idéologue
et d'ailleurs il n'a pas totalement
écarté le président dans son allocution
d'avant-hier soir il n'a pas totalement
écarté l'idée maintenant de fermer les
frontières mais je crains que ce soit un
peu tard et je crains que ce qui ce se
goberger en ironisant sur sur le sur le
nuage de tchernobyl étaient eux d'une
grande stupidité parce que ce n'est pas
le virus
il a besoin d'un facteur humain pour
pour pouvoir passer lorsque ce vecteur
humain est porté et porteur d'un
passeport d'un pays à risque
il était peut-être hasardeuse de vouloir
à ce point
forcément se montrer excessivement
hospitalier moi je crois aux états
nations
je crois à l'intérêt des états nations
et vous aurez remarqué qu'aujourd'hui on
regarde ce qui se passe en france
essentiellement on ne regarde pas quelle
est la situation générale d'une europe
qui est assez fantomatique et imaginaire
justement vous parlez d'une europe 1 et
ce sont vos mots observe également que
la russie puisque jeu puisque je
m'adresse excusez moi puisque je
m'adresse à aa une à une chaîne russe
j'observe également la russie qui a un
certain sens de la nation a également
décidé de se protéger au niveau des
frontières alors le bilan humain
s'alourdit de jour en jour en 120 morts
en espagne 1200 en italie 79 morts en
france est-ce que vous pensez que
l'union européenne soutient comme elle
le doit suffisamment ses états membres
victimes de cette épidémie de grenade
virus mais non mais je l'attends
je n'attends rien de l'union européenne
je n'ai jamais rien attendu de l'union
européenne j'attends j'attends une
protection de l'état nation auquel
j'appartiens du personnel médical de
l'état nation qu'elle j'appartiens avant
tout et je connais que c'est à ce stade
là où nous avons un assez bon même s'il
est malheureusement décadence un assez
beau système pi hospitalier c'est le
sait le je veux dire il nous avons été
excessivement hospitalier ce qui n'a pas
beaucoup
protéger notre système hospitalier si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire en même
temps pardon pour l'expression en même
temps celui qui vous parle ne tremble
pas tous encore par rapport coronavirus
je pense que nous nous en sortirons il
faut pas non plus être apocalyptique et
ça sera le mot de la fin j'ai lu william
goldnadel merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président d'avocats sans frontières